so how i have learned about iff is kind
of a funny story because i was working
for 25 years in the pharmaceutical
industry and then
somebody reached out to me whether i
want to be an independent director on
iff sport but i had no idea what this
company is i had not even an idea what
the industry is but then i learned so
much and it convinced me that this is a
real fun industry an industry where you
get
art and science combined and that's
really really something which attracted
me uh to be on the board of iff and then
later become ceo and chairman
[Music]
iff may not be a company you've heard of
but you've almost certainly used one of
their clients
products we went to the headquarters in
new york city to see just exactly how
these products are made smelling and it
was pretty mind-blowing
yeah oh yeah look we just do 20 of our
business in the us and the rest is
international so we have basically most
of our employees
somewhere asia
probably 20 25 percent europe probably
30 30 35 and then latin america and and
and north america
look if you ask me how you get exposed
to some of the iff technologies or
products and you go into a supermarket
or in a duty-free shop i would guess
in in one of five or one of six products
there's certainly an iff technology it
could be a plant-based burger which is
entirely made of iff ingredients and
technologies it could be a fragrance you
wear which is a complete iff
creation where we have invented the
molecules where we have done the
creation with all perfumers and we have
manufactured it so all of that could be
exposed to you as a consumer
andrew stavig was running bear's 12
billion pharmaceutical business for a
really long time he's taken that kind of
pharma ceo energy to iff
engineered a bunch of really big mergers
including a 26 billion dollar merger
with dupont nutrition business which is
why now iff has one of the clearest and
strongest
platforms to be developing plant-based
protein
we think just broader than flavors and
fragrances we think about total
solutions we think about innovative and
very creative spaces to go
like the whole plant-based meat space
where we believe it it's good for
sustainability it's good for health we
wanted to be a player there and they
have a couple of other areas in
particular in the biotech field which
were very very attractive for iff
so what we have here is a robot which is
basically mixing all these
creations to make sure that our
customers get get the first tests
already
yeah this is a robot which is doing it
all on it on its own so you don't need
any people you just put the formula in
and it's mixing it automatically
the most fun for me is is basically
talking to our researchers talking to
our creators about new products what can
we do what can we invent and what can we
bring to our customers and to the
consumers that's that's a big fun part
and i can tell you we have a lot of very
very creative and very knowledgeable
employees and i think we have a very
good atmosphere in the company as well
there are a lot of formulas and a lot of
things which we test out with consumers
and with our customers customers as well
here everything is is data
and facts and i would say that something
which is very important to me as well
and and that might be important about
iff is that we are a company where
research and development plays an
important role so we have always a very
data driven driven approach the whole
aspect of sustainability or esg is much
much more important these days and i'm
so happy that we started already seven
or eight years ago to put a real focus
uh be behind that for iff it's pretty
obvious uh we have brought the company
from around about 2.9 billion in sales
to
11.5 billion in sales and certainly the
market cap has has increased quite
significantly as well with that a lot of
changes have happened in in the company
but i believe for the better because the
company is now
very well positioned to be very
successful for the next next decade
because we have literally all the
ingredients to be successful
you